اهلا بكم مجددا التغطيه المستمره في اليوم
الثاني الثامن تحديدا من الاشتباكات في
السودان الجميع يريدوا ان يغادر معظم دول
العالم تريد اخراج رعاياها ودبلوماسيه في
اسرع وقت ممكن فالوضع اصبح غير امن على
الاطلاق وفي اليوم الثامن ايضا تظهر ازمه
جديده ازمه غذاء ونقص في الخبز ليعاني
السودان من ثنائيه الخوف والجوح
[موسيقى]
الجيش السوداني اعلنا ان عمليه رعايه كل
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الرعايه من
بريطانيا ورعاية بريطانيا والولايات
المتحده وفرنسا والصين ستتم خلال ساعات
بواسطه طائرات عسكريه واضاف الجيش
السوداني ان هذه الخطوه تاتي بعد استجابه
القائد الاعلى للجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان لطلبات رؤساء عدد من الدول الذين
اجروا اتصالات معه
هذا واعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه عن
بدء ترتيب اجراء المواطنين السعوديين وعدد
من رعايه الدول شقيقه من السودان الى
المملكه وذلك وفق ما نقلته وكاله الانباء
السعوديه
الى ذلك اوعز الرئيس الكوريه الجنوبي
بارسال وحده بحريه الى شواطئ السودان
لحمايه المواطنين الكوريين الجنوبيين وقال
المتحدث الرئاسي ان الرئيس او عزاء بنشره
وحده جونغهاي لمكافحه القرصنه بشكل فوري
عند شواطئ السودان لحمايه المواطنين
الكوريين الجنوبيين وارسال طائره عسكريه
الى القاعده الامريكيه في جيبوتي للتحضير
لاجلاء رعايه كوريا الجنوبيه بسبب
الاشتباكات المسلحه بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني
الخرطوم الدكتور عبد الناصر سلم مدير
برنامج شرقي فيقياء والسودان في فوكس
السويديه للابحاث اهلا بك دكتور مع
استمرار المواجهات والاشتباكات التي
تشهدها العاصمه السودانيه هل الاوضاع
برايك مواطيه لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
والعرب من العاصمه السودانيه
الاستضافه الرحمه والمغفيه لكل الشهداء
الذين سقطوا في هذه
الاحداث المؤسسه حقيقه افاقنا اليوم
في الخرطوم وكنا نعتقد بانه الهدنه سوف
يتم الالتزام بها لكن للاسف لم يلتزم
الطرفين
الانسانيه التي اتفقوا عليها في الامس لم
يتم فتح الممرات الامنه وعلى ما اعتقد انه
هناك مشكله حقيقيه تواجه اليوم
المواطنين السودانيين مع النقص الملحوظ في
في الخبز النقص الملحوظ في المواد
الغذائيه والنقص الملحوظ ايضا في الخدمات
المقدمه للمستشفيات يعني على ما اعتقد انه
اغلبيه المستشفيات اليوم في
العاصمه القوميه بعد بعد كل هذه الايام من
الصراع سوف وصلت الى مرحله ممكن ان تتوقف
في اي لحظه وهذا ما ينزل بكارثه بكارثه
حقيقيه فيما فيما يتعلق باجلاء رعايه
البلد الاجنبيه على ما اعتقد ان هذا الامر
يرسل اشارات واضحه جدا بانه اقتراح سوف
يستمر الى الى الى فتره اطول وان التهدئه
هذه او التهدئه النسبيه التي
اتفق عليها الطرفين في الامس كانت مرتبطه
بتسجيل خروجها رعايه ودبلوماسيه عدد من من
البلدان الاوروبيه
ننقل سؤال للمحلل العسكري الفريق فتح
الرحمن محي الدين فريق فتح الرحمن اذا سيد
البرهان التزم للدول التي تواصلت معه
بتامين خروج رعاياها ودبلوماسيها من
العاصمه الخرطوم هل الجيش في هذه المرحله
قادر على تامين خروج امن لهؤلاء
المشاهدين
انا اعتقد الجيش قادر جدا كل الرعايه في
اي وقت ما اراد
وا ذلك لازم هنالك مشكله الجيش في السيطره
كامله على الاحداث في الخرطوم بالاضافه
لان 17 ولايه من ولايه السودان كلها امنه
تمام
ا
اكثر من ثمانيه اطارات كلها يمكن ان
تستخدم لمثل هذا العمل يعني هنالك عده
خيارات وعده بدائل
يستفيد منها تستفيد منها اراده تجلي رعايه
هذه الدول يعني لازم هنالك
طيب ولكن مع تعطل الحركه في مطار الخرطوم
اي طرق اعمل لخروج اولئك الرعايه
وهذا المسلحه سيط
رتها لكان صحيح مطار
الخطيئه
هنالك موقع حي المطار الذي تسيطر عليه
عناصر الدعم السريع وتتخذ من سكان الحي
درعا بشريا تحمي نفسها فيه هذا الحجم
تماما الاطار وبالتالي لا تستطيع ان تعتبر
مطار الخرطوم امن وبالتالي مثال الخرطوم
يعني
متنازع السيطره ما بين القوات المسلحه
وعناصر الدعم السريعه لكن هنالك عده نترات
اخرى او كل المثارات الاخرى تحت سيطره
القوات المسلحه يعني
يكابر في ذلك يعني لانه سمعنا المتحدث
باسم الدعم السريع يقول اننا نسيطر على كل
المطارات في السودان
يعني لا لا وجود اي سيطره لديه في اي اطار
بخلاف اطار الخرطوم الذي ذكرنا بجودهم
فيها
ومن السائل يعني ان اراد
الرعايه هؤلاء تغسلهم الى المكان الذي
يمكن ان تاخذه منه يعني ليس الامر
قد يمثل تحدي فريق فتح الرحمن في هذه
المرحله لا رعايه الاجانب ولكن في ظل
استمرار الاشتباكات كما نتابع بشكل مباشر
في هذه الاصوات المتقطعه لاطلاق النار من
الذي سيوفر الحمايه اذا للمواطنين
السودانيين في العاصمه في ظل اجلاء المزيد
من الرعايه الاجانب اذا حدث ذلك
كان الغرض منه اصلا توفير الحمايه
للمواطنين وجد هذا العمل استحسانا كبيرا
من المواطنين وشاهدنا ذلك حتى عبر
المواطنين يخرج الى الشارع ويستقبلون
لغات المسلحه ترسل مناشدات للمواطنين في
منازلكم الاسماء تمشيط الشوارع لانه هذه
من الاوقات الخطر على المواطن
تبادل الاغنام بعد المتمردين وبالتالي
يصغب ضحايا من المواطنين لكن المواطنين
كانوا يصروا عبروا عن فرحتهم بوجود الجيش
في مناطقهم ويؤمن لهم
الطرقات حتى يتمكنوا من الحركه فهذا يعني
يؤكد ان القوات المسلحه هي التي تعامل
المواطن الان النشاط الذي تقوم به القوات
المسلحه في منطقه حله حمد حله وغسله بهذا
الغرض
لك احتلال
مين والعبد بالممتلكات الناس يعني تعمل
على اخلال من هذه المناطق حتى يتمتع
المناطق بالطمانينه في منطقه السكنيه
وحولها
طيب دكتور عبد الناصر اذا تمكنت الدول
الاجنبيه الاوروبيه او حتى دول المحيط
العربي من اجلاء رعاياها بامان من العاصمه
الخرطوم هل هذا يعطيها مساحه اكبر فيما
يتعلق باتخاذ موقف حازم مما يجري حاليا في
الخرطوم
ممكن ان تلعب البلدان العربيه والاوروبيه
دور كبير جدا في ان تضغط على الطرفين
للجلوس على الجلوس في طاوله التفاوض
والوصول الى نقاط محدده في هذه المرحله
هذا ما اعتقد انه نحن بحاجه الى الى ايجاد
اليه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق النار كي لا تنهار
المستشفيات وكي لا تزيد التكلفه البشريه
من من المواطنين ومراقبه او اليه لمراقبه
اطلاق النار واليه لمراقبه فتح الممرات
الامنه لعبوع الكوادر الطبيه على ما اعتقد
انه اليوم لم يستطع اي كادر طبي ان يذهب
الى الى المستشفيات ليقدم الخدمه
للمواطنين للجرحى او غيرها في هذه المرحله
هي مرحله وقف اطلاق النار الاليه الاليه
المطلوبه لمراقبه وقت اطلاله وبعد ذلك
نذهب الى مرحله اخرى ممكن ان تكون هي
مرحله التفاوض ما بين الفرقاء السوداني في
نهايه المطاف بعد ثمانيه ايام من الصراع
الدموي في في السودان على ما اعترض انه
هذه القضيه يجب على طاوله التفاوض
هو احسن او افضل
للسوداني من ان تحل في في الميدان طيب
ولكن هناك نقطه مهمه ايضا دكتور عبد
الناصر في حال
غياب
الرعايه الاجانب من العاصمه الخرطوم كما
تعلم بان هناك الكثير من المناطق التي
ربما شكلت نقاط حمراء فيما يتعلق
بالاشتباكات الاخيره اقصد المناطق
الدبلوماسيه الاحياء التي يقطم فيها
دبلوماسيون وما الى ذلك هل ستتحول الخرطوم
الى ساحه مواجهه مفتوحه في حال اجراء
اولئك الرعايه بشكل كامل
لا نتمنى ذلك باي شكل من من لكن على ما
اعتقد خروج الاعداد الدبلوماسيه من
العاصمه يرسل اشارات سالبه جدا جدا
لطرفايه الصراع بانه
يعني هذه المناطق قد اصبحت لكم مناطق
لتستمر فيها المعارك بعد خروج
الدبلوماسيين وخروج البسات الدبلوماسيه
وخروج الاجانب بصوره بصوره كامله يعني على
ما اعتقد انه الصراع في الفتره القادمه
هذه سوف يكون الشد
مما كان عليه بصوره كامله لان المرافقين
اليوم هي اللي هي البعثات الدبلوماسيه وهي
المنظمات العامله في السودان وللاسف
المنظمات اليوم جميعها تحاول ان تخرج من
من السودان لكن انا انا واثق جدا بانه
القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع في نهايه المطاف سوف يحتكم
الى لغه العقل وسوف يجلس في تعويضه
التفاوض لاخراج البلد ولحقن دماء
السوداني فهذه حرب ليس فيها ليس فيها
منتصر يا اخي الكريم في في نهايه المطاف
والمقتول طيب عبد الفتاح هل تتوقع اعطانا
الفريق عبد الرحمن هل تتوقع عفوا اللواء
عبد الرحمن هل تتوقع
المحلل العسكري الفتحه هل تتوقع بالفعل ان
تتحول العاصمه الخرطوم الى ساحه مواجهه
مفتوحه بعد اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب وهذا ما
يخشى منه السودانيون
يختلف تماما مع الدكتور عبد الناصر اولا
يعني الان القوات المسلحه عندما تمسك يدها
من التعامل مع المناطق التي تتحصن فيها
عناصر الدعم السريع لانها تتخذ من
المواطنين السودانيين لم يكن بين هؤلاء
المواطنين اجانب يعني هي تمسك يدها من
اي يعني ليس معظم الاجانب الان هم موجودون
في مناطق يعني امنه وحتى حديث الدكتور عبد
الناصر انهم مراقبون للحادث او للاحداث
التي تدور على
الارض انا اؤكد لكم الان هم داخل مجرات
سكنيهم وداخل ابواب مغلقه ويتحسنون داخل
بيوتهم حتى لا يتعرض لاي هذا ولكن اصلا لا
وجود لهم ولا راي لهم يسمعون اصوات
الانفجارات هنا وهناك تسمعها انت عبر
القنوات ويسمعها غيرك عبر الوسائل لكن لا
يوجد مراقبين ولا وجود ولا وجود لاجانب
يكونوا سبب في تقليل حجم الصراع في
المنطقه الصراع في المنطقه يقل بسبب وجود
المواطن السوداني الذي يكون بهيه لصراع ما
بين
المتمردين ولغات المسلحه واي حديث عن ان
هنالك صراعه من طرفين انا اعتقد هذا
الحديث مجافل الحقيقه الحقيقه ان هنالك
صراع ما بين القوات المسلحه السودانيه
السلطه الشرعيه في البلاد وما بين فصيل
متمرد عليها ليس هنالك طرفين وبالتالي اي
حديث الان عن ان هنا
لك يجب ان نجلس عليها انا اعتقد كلهم من
يقول ذلك ويصب في اتجاه الخيانه الوطنيه
لان ذلك يعني اننا نلبس الروح من جديد في
حركه التمرد بعد ان اصبحت غابه غسيل او
ادنى من الفناء يريدون ان يبعثوا فيها
الروح من جديد لنجلس على ما التفاوض ونحي
التمرد من جديد لكي تتكرر هذه الحرب ثانيه
اثنين بعد خمس سنين بعد
عشر نحن نحتفظ ان الان هذا وقت الحسد يجب
ان ينتهي هذا التمرد ينتهي بصوره البندقيه
وليس التفاوض والان نحن وصلنا الى
اد يمكن فيه ان نعتبر ان التمرض قد كسرت
شوكتني تماما هذه
اللعبه التي نشاهدها هي عباره عن مجموعات
متفلته متمرده تعمل حرب عصابات تنهب هنا
وتسرق من هنالك وتكسر هنا وهذا عمل اجرامي
ويجعل من اللغات المسلحه حق شرعي في ان
تتعامل معها وتبحرها لكي تؤمن المواطن لكي
تؤمن البلاد من هذا الخبز الذي يعني
ابتليت به فريق فتح الرحمن يتحدث عن طرفي
صراع طرف متمرد على طرف الاخر ولكن دكتور
عبد الناصر هل تتفق مع هذا الراي خاصه
فيما يتعلق بنظره المجتمع الدولي لما يجري
حاليا في الخرطوم
للقضيه السودانيه من الموضوع الانساني
بصوره كامله
في نهايه المطاف
الحدود الى الى تعبئه الاوضاع في في
الساحه السودانيه ذكرت لك قبل ذلك باننا
نعتقد بانه الحل في نهايه المطاف هو في
الفرقاء السودانيين وهذا هو راي المجتمع
الدولي بصوره كامله والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى الجامعه
العربيه
بصوره كامله يعني وهذه هي النقطه الاساسيه
كل الصراعات التي جاءت او التي كانت في
تاريخ السودان استمرت لسنوات الصراع في
جنوب السودان الصراع في دارفور الصراع في
غيرها في نهايه المطاف جلس
المجموعات المتصارعه او المتقاتله جلسوا
الى مائده الى الى الى مائده التفاوض
وهذه نقطه اخرى لابد من التعليق عليها من
الفريق فتح الرحمن هل تؤمن بالخيار
العسكري لحاسب المعركه ونحن نتحدث مره
اخرى عن طرفين وسبب في ذلك بان
القوى والمكون المدني المجتمع الدولي
ككلهم ينظرون الى طرفي نزاع ولا ينظرون
الى فريق متمرد ضد اخر
تصنيف خاطئ للازمه واي تصنيف خاطي توصيف
خاطئ اللازمه لا يساعد في حلها الحل في ان
هنالك سلطه شرعيه
حديث الاخ الدكتور عبد الناصر في ان كل
التمردات حسمت في الاخر بالتفاوض نقول نعم
كل التمردات كانت التمرد بغرض مطالب وليس
بغرض تفكيك الدوله هذا التمرد كان يهدف
الى انشاء جسم موازي للجيش الوطني يهدف
الى تفكيك الجيش الوطني والاستبداله
بالجيش المليشيات وهذا يعني تفكيك صمام
امان البلد يعني ذلك
الى دوله قابله تحويله السوداني الى مرت
لكل الحركات الارهابيه في العالم لكي يكون
مصدر لزعزعه كل الاقليم هذه هي الخطه وهذا
هو البرنامج الاستراتيجي الذي يعمل على
تنفيذه هؤلاء الخونه وبالتالي هذه المعركه
ليس هكذا ليس مثلك كافه حالات التمرد التي
شهدها السودان كل الحركات سواء كانت في
الجنوب في دارفور في جبال النوبه في النيل
الازرق في شرق السودان كانت تمردات لاجل
مطالب المواطن يشعر في تلك المناطق بانه
مصدوم وانه له حقوق يجب ان ينتزعها من
المركز يتمرد ويقاتل ويجلس مع المركز
وياخذ حقوبه عبر اتفاقيات سلام لكن هذا
التمرد يختلف بنسبه 180 درجه هذا تمرز
وجودي هذا تمرد يعني الغاء السوداني يلغي
الغاء وادي المسلحه السودانيه استبدال
ميليشيات الدعم السريع بلغات المسلحه
السودانيه وهذا يجعل هذه المعركه تختلف عن
كل المعارك ولابد ان تحسم بالبنوبيه وانا
اعتقد انها فعلا قد حسمت بالبندقيه ما
نسمح هذه الزوبعه المعرفه هذه الان حسبت
بالبندقيه المسلحه
حتى الازمه الانسانيه التي يروج لها
الناشطون الذين يدعوا الى تدخل دولي في
السودان اؤكد لك يا عزيزي ان الازمه
الانسانيه ليست بهذا الوضع البشع اولا يجب
ان نتحدث
فريق عبد الرحمن كيف ليست بهذا الوضع ما
زالت الجثث ملقاه في العديد من الشوارع
هناك اشخاص محاصرين في مناطق معينه هناك
ازمه طبيه طيب قلنا صحيح لو تكرمت
اقول لك الصحيح ارسل كاميرتك الى اي مكان
كانت
هذه الفريق العربيه مستعد وفريق اي محطه
اخباريه اخرى مستعد الى الوصول الى
المناطق التي تتحدث عنها لو استطاع الوصول
بامان لذلك لا نجد اي شخص يستطيع الان
النزول الى الشوارع السودانيه من اجل
تصوير حقيقه ما يجري
او كيف لا زالت موجوده هذا ما نقول لك
هنالك تاسيس لهذه القضيه هنالك سعيه
لتصوير يجب ان يفهم الجميع اولا ليست
الخرطوم بهذه المنطقه المركزيه التي يدور
حولها الصراع وليست السودان هو الخرطوم
السودان 18 ولايه الخرطوم ولايه واحده من
18 ولايه الخرطوم نفسها الان ثلاث ارباعه
الحياه فيها شبه طبيعيه يعني لا يمكن ان
نضاري الحقيقه ونتحدث عن المنطقه المركزيه
ويتحدثون عن ان هنالك 70% من الخدمات
الطبيه خارج السيطره والبقيه العربيه ولا
اي محطه اخرى هذا حديث الاشخاص المسؤولين
عن الوضع الصحي في السودان وكما تتابع محي
الدين الفريق محي الدين او فتح الرحمن
منظمه الصحه
الرحمن نحن نحيا نسعى بشكل كامل لنقل
الحقيقه والواقع هذه الصور التي تحدثت
عنها هي التي نقلت صور الجثث وصور القتله
طبعا كانت مصوره من اشخاص داخل مركباتهم
قد تكون عربات تابعه لجهات رسميه جهات
معينه ولكن اذا اذا وعد الفريق فتح الرحمن
محي الدين فتح الرحمن محي الدين بتامين
اولئك الصحفيين والمراسلين تاكد جيدا بان
الكل سيذهب الى الشوارع من اجل رصد حقيقه
ما يجري واذا كنت تتابع البيانات الرسميه
كان هناك رفض حتى من القوات المسلحه
لمتابعه عمليات التنشيط التي تجري في
الاحياء السودانيه ليس كذلك
الذي شاهدنا فيه
الجسامين يعني على مد البصر في منطقه كرري
اليوم العربيه نقل الصور من داخل هذا
المعسكر
سواحده على الارض هذا دليل على كل هذه
الجسدت هنالك كثير جدا من الجسر تم سترها
هنالك كثير جدا من المستشفيات التي تعمل
هنالك الكثير من الخدمات تصل الى الاحيان
وكانت كهرباء امنيه ولكن هؤلاء يدعو الى
تضليل الراي العام العالمي ويدعو الى
تصوير الوضع بانه بشع
والدولي
ه السودان وهذا هم يربوا اليه لكن نؤكد لك
ان الوضع مستقل المجتمع الاقليمي والدولي
مقتنع بفكره السودان بانه قادر على معالجه
هذه الازمه حتى هؤلاء
المنظمات الدوليه والسفارات التي ترغب في
ان تجلي رعاياها من السودان ترغب في
رعاياها من باب تامينه من خوف من التفلتات
الامنيه التي تحدث هنا وهناك استهداف مثل
هذه الاساسات بالتاكيد سيكونوا هم هدف
لهؤلاء المتفلتين خاصه بعد ان تم كسره سجن
الهدى بالامس وتحرير اكثر من 7000 مجرم من
كبار مجرمين السودان تم تحريرهم بالامس
هذا بالتاكيد سيلغي بذلال
سالم وليست في هذه الايام وبالتالي
البحثات الدبلوماسيه كونه تفكر تخرج
السودان مرحب بذلك لا يزعجه الامر
بشيء به من ارادوا ان ومرحبا بهم ان اراد
ان يجلسوا معنا ولكن سنعاني فعلا من
اضطراب امني لاننا نتواجه الان مع اصابات
متفلته اصبحت تعمل
من اي جهه
على تنظيف هذه الجيوب ونعتقد ان هذا الامر
الذي يدوم طويلا ستعودا الامور الى
طبيعتها ولكن خذوا معلومه الوضع الصحي من
دكتور محمد ابراهيم
تلفونه لديكم اتصل عليه وهو الناطق الرسمي
باسم وزاره الصحه ولايه الخرطوم يعطيكم كل
التفاصيل فيما يتعلق بدفن الجسامين فيما
يتعلق
بامداد والمياه للمستشفيات في كل هذه
الامور ستجدون الامور يعني تحت السيطره
تماما هؤلاء الذين يتحدثوا عن انه
يار والنبوءه والاخائيين لمده 12 شهر ولم
تنهار المنظومه الصحيه في الخرطوم وكيف
تتحدثون عن انهيار المنظومه الصحيه في
سبعه ايام هذا عبس وهذا سنعمل على تواصل
بشكل مباشر مع الدكتور محمد ابراهيم كما
طلبت وكما نعد بذلك ولكن اسمح لي ان اختم
مع الدكتور عبد الناصر يبدو بان المجتمع
الدولي كما يقول ضيفي من الخرطوم قد
استعجل فيما يتعلق بسحب الرعايه من
الخرطوم في هذه المرحله الجيش السوداني
القوات المسلحه قادره على تامين المناطق
بشكل كامل
والخوف فقط هو من العصابات المنفلته التي
قد تقوم بعمليات هنا وهناك هل هذا حقيقه
ما يحدث خاصه في مظل ما تحدث عنه ضيفي من
الخرطوم بان هناك مبالغه بشان حقيقه ما
يجري خاصه فيما يتعلق بالجانب الصحي
فيما يتعلق بالجانب الصحي هناك اشكاليه
حقيقيه هذا شيء لا يختلف عليه اثنين من من
المتابعين لهذه الازمه الازمه خلقت نوع من
النزوح وخلقت نوع من مقتل الامدادات
الاعتراض بهذه الحقيقه يقود الى ايجاد
علاج موضوعي لهذه الاشكاليات يعني انا
اعتقد اليوم ممكن امداد المستشفيات
بالمعينات الطبيه وممكن امداد المخابز
يتوفر الخبز للناس وممكن العمل على امداد
الوسائل المعيشه للمواطنين الصوره تقودهم
الى ان يستطيعوا ان يستمروا في يستمروا
بحياتهم الطبيعيه لكن الان هناك اشكاليه
صحيه وهناك اشكاليه في معاشي الناس هذا
لا
في في ساحه سودانيه مع احترامي شديد طبعا
لحديد
استاذنا الفاضل وما ذكره لكن هناك شريحه
حقيقيه موجوده تحتاج الى علاج المستشفيات
اليوم المناسبات التي خرجت خرجت من منظمه
الصحه العالميه خرجت من اطباء بلا حدود
خرجت من الاطباء السودانيين بما يعني انهم
هم المشرفين على هذا الوضع ويعلمون جيدا
خطوره الوضع الصحي وخطوره الاوضاع وخطوره
استمرار الحرب وعدم فتح الممرات الامنه
وعدم توفير المساعدات هناك ازمه حقيقيه
تحتاج الى انه نعترف بها ونعمل جميعنا
لعلاجها يا اخي الكريم
ونترك قضيه رمي
الاتهام الاخرين لانهم هم يحاولون
ان هذه حرب فيها قتال فيها ضحايا فيها
تشرد يحصل لعدد كبير مع احترامنا الشديد
طبعا لكل الاطراف الموجوده الموجوده لكن
الاعتراف الاعتراف بالوضع كما هو يقود الى
ايجاد حلول تضمن عدم انزلاق الناس او عدم
انزلاق الدوله الى دوامه اخرى من
الصراع ونتمنى الخير للسودان بكل ما
اوتينا من قوه دكتور عبد الناصر سلم مدير
برنامج شرق افريقيا والسودان في فوق
السويديه للابحاث شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا
ايضا للمحلل العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن
محي الدين
طبعا كاميرا العربيه رصدت لحظه قصف بالقرب
من جسر الخرطوم حيث تم سماع صوت انفجار
تلاهوا تصاعد كثيف للادخنه
طبعا كما تواجهون او تشاهدون على عواجل
العربيه سلطات الاردنيه الخارجيه الاردنيه
تحديدا تعلن العربيه انها بدات في عمليه
اجلاء 300 شخص من رعاياها موجودون في
السودان وسمعنا بان هناك محاولات من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بدء ترتيب اجلاء
الرعايه السعوديين بما فيهم بالطبع من
دبلوماسيين وعدد من عائلات الدول الشقيقه
ايضا من السودان وكان هناك تصريحات لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول فيها بان
الاولويه في هذه المرحله هي اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من هناك في ظل استمرار الاشتباكات
في العاصمه الخرطوم في المناطق متفرقه من
السودان ايضا قال شهود عيال العربيه ان
سته اشخاص من عائله واحده قتلوا واصيب شخص
اخر بجروح خطيره بعد سقوط قذائف مدفعيه
على حي المنصوره السكني في ام درمان
طبعا
التدوين من المدفعيه هنا
ضربت
البيوت جدا بيوتي
وانا مركب في الشارع
ايضا ضمن التغطيه المتواصله مراسل العربيه
يفيد بسماع ذوي انفجارات وتحليق للطائرات
في منطقه كرري في مدينه ام درمان مقاطع
فيديو متداوله اظهرت اشتعال النيران
وتصاعد اعمده الدخان في مبنى بنك الجزيره
في الخرطوم فلو تابعه
المشكله
متقاعد محمد عبد الواحد الخبير الامني
والمختص بالشؤون الافريقيه ومحمد اهلا
وسهلا بك ماذا يعني بدء او سعي الكثير من
الدول العربيه او حتى دوليه الى اجلاء
رعاياها من العاصمه الخرطوم
اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بمشاهدينك الكرام اولا
هذا الحدث بيعكس له دلاله بتعكس امور
كثيره ربما تزايد حده الصراع خلال الفتره
القادمه او توفرت الى الدول الاجنبيه من
خلال تواجدها الدبلوماسي او الاستخباراتي
من معلومات تؤكد ان الصراع في تطور مستمر
في السودان وربما ايضا نوع من لفت
الانتباه الى السودان خاصه وان انا شايف
ان الاعلام العالمي كله بيركز الانتباه
على السودان
وكانه برده مقصود من يعني ان انا ابعد
الانظار عن الاحداث في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه لاسيما وان الصراع في السودان
هو جزء لا يتجزا من استراتيجيه
الصراع الدولي ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وحلفائها من الغرب من جهه روسيا والصين من
جهه اخرى الحقيقه له دلالات كثيره لكن
اتخيل ان الصراع سوف ياخذ منحنيات اخرى
ربما يحدث عمليه صراعات مفتوحه داخل
العاصمه وقد تنتقل الى ولايات اخرى في
السودان خلال الايام القليله القادمه طيب
ولكن هناك اشكاليه كبيره فيما يتعلق
بتامين هؤلاء رعايه اذا كانت المعارك
محتدمه اذا كان هناك طرفان للنزاع كما
يقول الكثير بانها قوات مفتوحه في مواجهه
مفتوحه في العاصمه الخرطوم كيف يمكن
بالفعل تامين خروج رعايه اجانب اطفال نساء
وايضا اشخاص مختلفين ومن انتماءات مختلفه
من عاصمه تدور فيها اشتباكات مفتوحه بهذا
الشكل
دي حقيقه مسلمه خاصه ان كمان مطار الخرطوم
يعني في تضارب للانبياء هو لا يعمل حاليا
والسيطره على المطار يعني متبادله ما بين
الجيش السوداني وما بين قوات الدعم السريع
كل طرف يعلن على سيطرته على المطار من وقت
لاخر وبالتالي اتخيل ان عمليه الاجلاء سوف
تتم بالترتيب طبعا مع كل بعثه دبلوماسيه
موجوده هناك بيتم الاتصال بكافه الجاليه
اللي مسجله طبقا اللي موجوده في السفاره
وبيتم الاتفاق على تجميعهم في فتره من
فترات الهدنه مع الاتفاق مع الجيش
السوداني على توفير مكان بديل لمطار
الخرطوم ممكن من خلال المطارات الفرعيه
ممكن من خلال النقل اذا امكن الى مطار اخر
قريب بعيدا عن منطقه
الصراع وبيتم التنسيق مع الجيش السوداني
لان هو المعني بهذا في الوقت الحاضر كمان
انا ارى ان كلا الطرفين اتخيل اني يعني
هيكون حريص جدا على انه ما يوجهش ضرباته
او لا يوجه
البندقيه تجاه الاجانب لان كلا الطرفين
يريد
شرعيه ويريد قبول خاصه قوات الدعم السريع
تريد قبول دولي الصراع سيدي الفاضل همم
يجب ان نضعه في موضعه الطبيعي التاريخ
يدلل على ان كافه الصراعات في السودان هي
صراعات من اجل السلطه وبالتالي هذا الصراع
هو جزء من من من هذه المنظومه هو صراع على
السلطه في المنظومه
المنظومه السودانيه
المستفيد الوحيد من من هذا الصراع خلينا
نتحدث بموضوعيه شديده المستفيد الوحيد من
هذا الصراع هم الطرفين
الرعايه الاجانب بالمامن في ظل هذه
الاتهامات المتبادل
اه طبعا انا اتخيل ان الرعايه الاجانب في
مامن كل طرف يريد ان يوصل رساله الى
المجتمع الدولي الى الخارج انه هو الطرف
المقبول العاقل الرشيد في
السودان وانه هو قادر على تامين مصالح
الاجانب في المنطقه ودي نقدر نلاحظها من
خلال لو احنا حللنا نص الخطاب او نص
البيانات التي تصدر عن كل مؤسسه سواء
تحليل سياسي او تحليل حتى النص الادبي
حضرتك هتجد ان ان كل طرف بيسعى الى كسب ود
المجتمع الدولي وكل طرف بيسمعهم اللي
المجتمع الدولي يريد ان يسمعه الحقيقه هي
حرب كلاميه حرب بيانات ما بين الطرفين في
رسائل موجهه للداخل ورسائل اخرى موجهه
للخارج فكل طرف اتخيل هيكون حريص على على
يعني ارسال صوره للخارج بانه هو الطرف
المتحضر من هذا الصراع وعندنا يعني خير
دليل موضوع الجنود المصريين كان خير دليل
تمت هذا الموضوع بسهوله ويسر وتم نقلهم
الى القاهره في فترات من فترات الهدنه
اتخيل ان كل الطرفين حريص على تامين
الرعايه الاجانب
اللي هو المتقاعد محمد عبد الواحد الخبيره
الامنيه والمختص بشرى الافريقيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
اعزائنا المشاهدين استمع الان لهذا
التسجيل وهذه الكلمه لنائب رئيس الاركان
السوداني عبد المحمود
العجمي في تفقده او لدى تفقده عددا من
الوحدات في العاصمه الخرطوم
فقط
لذلك ما في ودنه
[تصفيق]
القياده بتاعتنا غدا وضع الانساني في
المستشفيات والاطفال والرضع قال ممكن تكون
في هدنه بغرض انسان فقط الهدنه ما بدات
لذلك ما في ودنه
وعرفوا بالجبن وعرفوا بالاعتداء لا دين
ولا اخلاق اليوم المشاهد
يخدموا في اجنده بتاع الدول الخارجيه الان
الدول الخارجيه ضايعه خله قالوا دين منظمه
ارهابيه او بمجموعه بتاع العصابه الحراميه
الناس فيما تبقى من يوم يومين ان شاء الله
نعلن الخرطوم به
اذا تبعنا كلمه في عدد من الجنود لنائب
رئيس الاركان عبد المحمود
العجميه الفريق عبد المحمود وهناك حديث
واتهامات لقوات الدعم السريع بانها قوات
لا تلتزم بالهدن وان اي هدنه في السودان
لازم تكون لابد ان تكون هدنه انسانيه فقط
مع وعد بانهاء المواجهات خلال يومين
الكاتب السوداني المتخصص لشؤون الافريقيه
محمد طورشيني ينضم الينا من باريس هل هذا
ممكن هل من الممكن بالفعل انهاء المواجهات
في الخرطوم خلال يومين
في البدء التحيه لكم
المشاهدين الكرام انا في تقديري وفقا
للمعطيات التي تحدث منذ تجدد المواجهات او
اندلاع هذه المواجهات فرضيه ايقافها او
انحساره الان اصبحت غير وارده باي حال من
الاحوال لانه منذ البدء هذا هو صراع على
السلطه والثروه والنفوس فكل طرف يحشد قواه
امكانياته من اجل الانتصار على الطرف
الاخر والان التحشيد تم من خلال الهدنه
التي اطلقها الطرفين الغرض منها تحديد
اكبر قدر ممكن من الحجز والتحشيط والحصول
على الامدادات فبالتالي من الصعبه جدا ان
سيكون هناك
فعلي او يكون هنالك حوار ويبدو لي محاوله
البعثات الدبلوماسيه اجنار رعايه هذا دليل
واش قوي جدا بان لديهم معلومات تؤكد بان
الصرع مستمر فقط تتوقف مع هذه رساله تسجيل
الصوتي لمكالمه هاتفيه
الاتحاد المكلف مع التلفزيون وكذلك
قذف وضرب كثير جدا اثر على امداد الكهرباء
وامداد الماء نتيجه لوجود
تاثير هذه
المستشفيات في ولايات اخرى كان فيها تاثير
على المستشفيات ولايه
شمال الكردفان بصوره اساسيه
تمت بعض الترتيبات على اساس انه الناس
عملت اخلاء لهذه المستشفيات
نقل المرضى من هذه المستشفيات لمستشفيات
اخرى في ولايه الخرطوم ويتم نشر هذه
القوائم لهذه المستشفيات
بصوره يوميه في محليات الخرطوم السبعه وفي
غيره من الولايات بالنسبه
للامدادات الموجود
ويوجد بعض الامداد هنالك شحث في بعض
المواد من قبل الفتره دي ولكن ما هو موجود
توجد صعوبه في ايصال الامداد الامدادات
المركزيه ما تاثرت كانت هنالك مشكله في
الوقود لها وتم التنسيق مع
وزاره الطاقه على ستار لايصال الامداد
الوقود بالنسبه لهم وطمنوهم في هذا الجانب
للاسف المركز الامداد الرئيسي مخزن
امدادات الرئيس تي في ولايه جنوب دارفينيا
نتعرض للاهلاك الكامل والحرق الكامل
دي بالنسبه للصوره الكليه الاولويات
بالنسبه لنا حاليا احنا هي مسائل التامين
المستشفيات والمرافق الصحيه العامله خرج
كبير من الخدمه زي ما ذكرتها القطاع العام
القطاع الخاص
تلك المستشفيات تقريبا حاليا الخدمه وزي
ماستفادي هي مركزيه نقاط اشتباك في الغالب
او تاثرت بصوره مباشره نتيجه لضرب
السلاسل الامداد في الكهرباء والمويه
وبرضو انها غير امنه للكوادر الطبيه وللوص
للمرضى كذلك
من الاولويات هي التامين هذه المؤسسات
الصحيه تدامين الكوادر الطبيه تامين وسائل
النقل خاصه للاسعافات للمرضى
بالنسبه لنا تاثرت بعض الاسعافات وهي
بتنقل المرضى وبتنقل الاسطاف لبعض
المستشفيات في تم التعرض لها في
الطرق يعني المساله الثانيه هي تامين وصول
الامداد للمستشفيات سواء كان الامداد
الدوائي او سكان الامداد الغذائي للغذاءات
او سواء كان امداد الوقود الورد تامين
المساله الثالثه برضو
هي ضروره
تعميم الكوادر الطبيه في ايضا تبعنا جانبا
من الاتصال الهاتف الدكتور هيثم محمد
ابراهيم وزير الصحه الاتحادي المكلف في
السودان ويتحدث عن الصعوبات التي تواجه
القطاع الطبي في ظل خروج عدد كبير من
المستشفيات من الخدمه وصعوبه ايصال
المساعدات الطبيه والانسانيه الى
المستشفيات المحتاجه كما اشرنا مع خروج
الكثير منها من الخدمه وهذا يدل على الوضع
الصحي المتردي في العاصمه السودانيه كنا
نحاول الاتصال على احد من وزاره الصحه
ومن باب صدفه خرج وزير الصحه بنفسه على
القناه الرسميه لاتحدث عن الصعوبات التي
تواجه القطاع الصحي في السودان اعود مره
اخرى الى ضيفي محمد طورشيد سيد محمد يواجه
الاعلاميون بشكل كبير وبشكل استثنائي
صعوبه في التحقق من المعلومات الوارده من
طرفي النزاع في الخرطوم انتم كيف تتابعون
هذا المشهد خاصه في ظل هذا التضارب الكبير
في الانباء والمعلومات الوارد من العاصمه
الوارده من العاصمه السودانيه
الحصول على معلومه صادقه ودقيقه تخضع
لادوات وسائل الصحفيه واعلاميه للتحقق
بالنقته وصحتها امر يجب صعوبه جدا لا يتم
ادمان الحروب والمعارك ومعلوم تماما انه
الان كله طرف بحاول بشكله باخر ان يكسب
المعرفه الاعلاميه سواء كان على التواصل
الاجتماعي او عن طريق البيانات التي
ينصرها حتى تكون هي مصدر للمعلومات
لوكالات الانباء وكذلك للصحف والقنوات
فانا في تقديري الان في هذه الاوضاع انا
من الصعب جدا اؤكد لك بان يمكن لاي حل من
الاحوال لان نثق فيه في معلومات الطرفين
يعتبر انه كل تحديد مكاسب اعلاميه لكن
هنالك بعض التواصل مع الجهات ذات
المصداقيه لكن المعلومات التي تقدمها اول
المصادر تعكس بعض الحقائق في في مناطق
معينه او في الجزئيات معينه باعتبار ان
الحركه الخاصه في معدمه
التحرك دائما يتم حسابات وتقديرات معينه
فبالتالي من الصعب جدا ان يكون هنالك
صدق في مصر كل هذه المعلومات ماعدا في
نطاق الجغرافي ضيق انا في تقدير للاسف
الشديد في ازمير الحروف الحقيقه وكذلك
البعد الانساني هم ضحايا
المواجهات وهذه الحروب وهذا يظهر جلينا
الان في الحاله السودانيه الامر الذي جعل
حتى البعثات الدبلوماسيه تخشى على رائها
وتحاول تجعلهم يخرجون من السودان وحتى
يعني في هذه الماده
روايتين في هذه النقطه بالتحديد الروايه
الاولى تقول بان الاحداث خفت وتراجعت
وتيره الاشتباكات فاصبح من الامن مثلا
اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب العاصمه الخرطوم
هذه الروايه الاولى الروايه الثانيه تقول
بان الامور في طريقها للمزيد من التصعيد
فلذلك اتخذت هذه الخطوه على اي الرائيين
او الى اي الرايين تميل سيد محمد
الحالتين ان هنالك حتى في مساله اجلال
الرعايه الاجانب لنرى انه في صباح اليوم
الدعم السريع تحدث عنه قادر على الفتح
الجزئي للمطارات وفعليا على ارض الواقع
وفقا للمعلومات الوارده ان الدعم السريع
العام فعليا لا يسيطر عليه مطر بسبب كان
يسيطر
والان كل هذه المطارات
المسلحه هذا ما يعجز لك حجم الحرب والحرب
المضاده اعلاميا في الاتجاه الاخر وهو
الاتجاه المهم جدا في تقديره الان كل طرف
يحاول ان يكسب بعدين مهمين جدا هم البعد
الدولي من خلال استجابه اي طرف منهما
بفكره المباحثات او بفكره الهدنه التي يتم
اطلاقها سواء كان من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او من قبل
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي هذه
الجزئيه والجذير اخرى محاوله كسب الشعب
يتوارى ان هذه المعركه في اساسها الصراحه
والسلطه والثروه فبالتالي البعد الشعبي
فيها مهم هنالك اتهامات متبادله من كل طرف
بانه هو الذي يطلق النار اتجاه هو الذي
يستهلك الخدمات ايقاف مستشفى هذا
الامدادات الدوائيه حرف الاسواقما الى ذلك
فانا في تقدير الحرب هي معطياتها معقده
متداخله جدا اي طرف يحاول الكذب بجزئين
مهمين او بعدين مهمين جدا البعده الانسان
الداخل وكذلك المجتمع الدولي حتى يستطيع
انه يحقق مكاسب باعتبار انه الحرب كله طرف
الان وصل الى هذه القناعه التي جعلتهم
يوصلون الى هذه النقطه ويدخلون في هذه
الحرب لان مساحات وفرص التوصل الى تسويه
سياسيه او التوصل الى تفاهم شبهي معدومه
باعتبار الان
التحالف هذا التحالف العسكري كان هو انقض
على التجربه الديمقراطيه احد 25 اكتوبر
منطقه الافتراق ولكن اسمح لي بالانتقال
الى لندن مع رانيا الصايغ عضو منظمه اطباء
السودان من اجل حقوق الانسان
سيد رانيا هل لنا براي محايد فيما يتعلق
بالوضع
الصحي في العاصمه الخرطوم
الاسلاميه بالسود حبيب بالف خير
الوضع الصحي
والانساني في السودان للاسف من سيء لاسوء
يعني الهدنه لم تنجح وحسب الافادات من
الارض كما اردتم في قناتكم انه ما زال
القصف مستمر ما زالت اكثر من 70% من
مستشفيات الخرطوم خارج الخدمه والمستشفيات
العامله نفسها فاقت سعتها الاستيعابيه
الكوادر الطبيه العامله في المستشفيات
وانهكت تماما لانه نفس الاشخاص يعملون منذ
ثمانيه ايام وسط نقص حاد في الامداد
الدوائي والمعينات والاكسجين واكياس الدم
والادويه المنقذه للحياه ايضا تراكم الجثث
في الشوارع سيتسبب عما قريب في كارثه
بيئيه كبيره
انقطاع المياه مياه الشرب والمياه النظيفه
منذ ثمانيه ايام تماما في بحري بسبب تعرض
محطه المياه الرئيسيه في مدينه بحري للقصف
انعدام مياه الشرب المياه المعدنيه في
المحاله التجاريه
نفاذ المواد الغذائيه من البيوت ضعف
الامداد من المصانع والشركات بل هو
الحقيقه انعدام الامداد يعني من المصانع
والشركات للمواد الغذائيه والدوائيه في
ايضا نقص حاد في البنزين والوقود مما
يتسبب ايضا في مفارقه الاوضاع سوء وزياده
النقص في الامداد الدوائي والغذائي
واستحاله حركه الطواقم الطبيه وطواقم
الانقاذ وعمليات الاجلاء
المنظمات الدوليه سيده رانيا هل لديه
القدره على الوصول الى تلك المناطق هل
لديها القدره على ايصال المساعدات
الامدادات الطبيه
المساهمه بشكل او باخر في تخفيف العبء
الطبي على الكادر الطبي والقطاع الطبي في
الخرطوم
للاسف يعني لا احد يستطيع التحرك بامان
يعني تعرضت سته سيارات اسعاف للقصف
المباشر غير انه في عدد من سيارات الاسعاف
تعرضت للنهد والاختطاف يعني فما في اي جهه
سواء يعني حكوميه او من المنظمات الدوليه
العامله في السودان قادره على اي انواع من
المساعدات للاسف طيب
بالقرب من مطار الخرطوم وطبعا كان من
المؤمن ان يكون هذا المطار نافذه من اجل
اجلال الرعايه الاجانب او من يحاول الهروب
من جحيم ما يجري في الخرطوم تفضل السيد
رانيا كنت تتحدثين عن المزيد من التفاصيل
نعم قبل قليل كنت على الهاتف مع
احد العاملين في منظمه اطباء
اطباء بلا حدود واخبرني عن انهم يعني
يحاولون ايصال المساعدات للسودان ولكنهم
يريدون توفير يعني مسارات امنه ومطار امن
لانزال طائراتهم او او بواخرهم او قواربهم
الى السودان ولكنهم لم يعني يحصلوا على
وعود مؤكده من اي جهه النوم يعني حيكونوا
في امان اذا انزلوا طائراتهم وعامليهم الى
السودان
فده دليل كبير على انه المنظمات الدوليه
يعني تحتاج الى مسارات امنه ومطارات امنه
لانزال المساعدات في السودان طيب فقط هل
لديكم اي ارقام
فيما يتعلق بضحايا هذه المواجهات حتى الان
مطابقه تماما لما اردتموه في قناتكم عن
اعداد القتلى والجرحى من من نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين طبعا للقتله
بالمئات خاصه مع استمرار الاشتباكات لليوم
الثامن على التوالي راني صايغ عضو منظمه
اطباء
من اجل السودان من اجل حقوق الانسان شكرا
جزيلا لك اعد مره اخرى الى محمد طرشين
نقطه مهمه جدا كل الدول تسعى لاخراج
رعاياها من اتون هذه المواجهات المستمره
في العاصمه الخرطوم وهذه لقطات مباشره
لمطار الخرطوم كما نتابع في هذه اللقطات
طبعا المطار خارج من الخدمه وعلى الخدمه
من يوم السبت الماضي بعد استهداف عدد من
الطائرات في داخل
مدرج المطار وهناك محاولات
لاحياء الوضع داخل هذا المطار او اعادته
الى الخدمه سريعا من اجل على الاقل ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه سيد محمد طورشين اذا
الدول تسعى لاخراج رعاياها ودبلوماسيها
بشكل سريع من الخرطوم ولكن من الذي يستطيع
حمايه الشعب السوداني من هذه المواجهه
المستمره والتي تحولت الخرطوم من خلالها
الى اشبه بساحه حرب
انا المواطن السوداني مطرقه الدعم السريع
وبكل تاريخه الاسيه وكذلك القوات المسلحه
بكل تجاوزاتها وبكل اخفاقاتها الان وفي ظل
انتشار موجات من السلب والنهب والامتداء
على المتاجر وعلى الاسواق انا في تقدير
الان الشعب السوداني ليس اعمامه فرصه الا
تنظيم نفسه وترتيب حاله عن طريق الايجار
للدفاع الذاتي من اجل تامين الاحياء اولا
فيما يتعلق بالاعتداعات وكذلك توفير
القنوات الاساسيه من سلاح تموينيه وكذلك
توفير حتى ابار من اجل حل مشاكل للمياه
وهذه مسائل مهمه جدا لانه الان كلهم
مؤشرات في ظل ما يحدث تؤكد بانه محمد
الحرب لن ينتهي قريبا كذلك الان البعثاس
الدواسيه التسارع من اجل انقاذ رعايه
والان الظاهر القوات المسلحه من خلال
التصريحات البعثات الدبلوماسيه التزمت
يعني توفر طائرات عموديوم الروحيه تقل
الرعايه هذه البلدان وكذلك الاطقم
الدبلوماسيه من الخرطوم الى بورسودان
ذهبوا الى بلدان فالظاهره الان انه مطر
بورسودان سيكون محطه مهمه جدا في ظل
انتشار عدد من الاقوات الغربيه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وفرنسا والصين وكوريا
واليابان وفي هذا يؤكل
الاشخاص بابان الى تلك المناطق مرورا بعدد
من الشوارع التي تشهد اشتباكات متقطعه
الكاتب السوداني المتخصص للشؤون الافريقيه
محمد توغشين شكرا جزيلا لك فقط مشير الى
الصور التي نشاهدها قبل قليل وشدناها قبل
قليل من المطار الخرطوم يبدو بان هناك
حريقا اندلع بالقرب او داخل المطار كما
شاهدنا في اللقطات سابقه هذا المطار معطل
بشكل كامل عن الخدمه بعد الوصول المواجهات
اليه في اليوم الاول من الاشتباكات فلا
يستطيع احد استخدام هذا المطار سواء
للخروج او حتى للدخول من اجل ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه او حتى التوسط لانهاء
هذه الازمه المحتدمه لليوم الثامن على
تاون
الكاميرا العربيه رصدت ازمه الخبز التي
بدات في الظهور في الخرطوم حيث ظهرت
الطوابير امام الافران بحثا عن الخبز
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات